Nice
Ja Leute, moin, schon so viele am Start, ich fahr grad den Streamingrechner hoch, der sagt
ich hab grad überhaupt meinen Rechner eingeschaltet, lull, exzellent, was ist das denn, ist das
Elefant, ein gecombratet Elefant, so Streamingrechner startet, so ich hab mich schon eine Stunde
oder eineinhalb Stunden bewegt heute, Sachen gibts, muss ja nicht noch dicker werden als
ich schon bin, pepe fett, lull, so mein Sound ist irgendwie grad weg aber ich glaub ihr
hört noch was, ja, ja jetzt ist er wieder da, im jeden Fall war ich noch einkaufen, da
war heute richtig voll, erst mal hier Monka Corona gemacht als ich wieder daheim war,
heute Abend Leute, heute Abend ist, deswegen ich bin jetzt auch nur kurz da, quasi Mittagspause
Stream, heute Abend ist ja Apple Event 2020, ist hier WWDC, was gibts hier, Predictions,
mal gucken was heute Abend, iOS 14, Leaker Predictions, ok da wird immer alles geleaked,
MacRumors, ok was rumort der Mac, mein Mac rumort übrigens nichts, weil ich hab keinen,
wo kehrst du, was juckt mich, was irgends ein Typ auf Twitter schreibt, vielleicht ein
Monitorhalter für 1000, ja, Triboder hab ich auch grad dran gedacht, Monitorhalter für
1000 Euro, Wesermount für 200 Euro, excellent, Top, ok Predictions, ok Predictions, was
Predicted
Gucken wir heute Abend, heute Abend 19 Uhr gucken wir das zusammen. Ich hoffe man darf das Restream
Mittlerweile mehr online als offline, ja ich hätte das, hättet ihr mir das mal vor einem Jahr erzählt oder so, da hätte ich gedacht, null verarsch mich nicht
Da ich so viel am streamen bin, aber mittlerweile kommt mir fast den Tag ohne streamen an, so vor als hätte ich nichts gemacht, ist schon merkwürdig
Und man muss sagen da schlägt sich auch in Subscriberzahlen und allem nieder, also ich glaube ich hatte noch nie so viele Subscriber, wie aktuell
Ich glaube sogar mehr als Weihnachten
Ich glaube sogar mehr als an Weihnachten
Oder knapp, vielleicht knapp weniger
Aber auf jeden fall nicht, nicht viel weniger
Okay, iOS 14, ja gut da rechne ich ehrlich gesagt auch mit, weil ich meine die sind schon bei iOS 13.5, na da muss ja iOS 14 mal jetzt kommen
Das, das halt ich für nahezu sicher
Build in translator, okay das halt ich für gar nicht so abwegig, translator, machine learning gestützte translator Sachen sind, sind voll, voll im Trend, hier Diepel
Ist ja so der, der neueste Hype was das angeht
Ist ja so der, der neueste Hype was das angeht, wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal ob der, ob der deutsch, ob der Twitch Chat kann
Der Twitch Chat ist besonders cute Chat heute, ajaja
Okay, translate in englisch
Moment, moment, translate, englisch, german in englisch
Der Twitch Chat, ah moment, the Twitch Chat is especially cute Chat today, ey so die Übersetzung ist ziemlich gut
Die Übersetzung ist ziemlich gut, mein Chef will wissen was ich gerade für Programmiervideos sag AI, Python Deep Learning AI
AI, übrigens habt ihr mal die GitHub Language Statistik angeguckt, find das eigentlich ganz interessant
Also ich mein es ist nicht verwunderlich, dass auf GitHub JavaScript auf dem ersten Platz ist
JavaScript ist, aber das muss man echt sagen, dass Python gleich auf dem zweiten Platz ist okay finde ich jetzt auch nicht so überrascht
Aber Java und wisst ihr warum Java, aber erstens gibt es natürlich schon viele bestehende Produkte und sonst was
Aber die Chinesen, die Chinesen stehen unglaublich auf Java, ich weiß nicht so genau warum, vielleicht mögen die Microsoft nicht
und denken sich okay bevor wir mit C Sharp anfangen machen wir lieber Java, aber die Chinesen die stehen total auf Java Zeug
Wenn ihr mal auf GitHub guckt, wenn ihr mal auf GitHub Trending guckt, da werdet ihr feststellen, dass die das erstens sau viele chinesische Sachen trenden
Mal die Woche, hier ist auch viel chinesische Sachen trenden, hier sowas da und Spring Boot es ist Java, fast alles was chinesisch ist und trendet ist Java
Die sind 15 Jahre hinterher schreibt der Patrick, vielleicht sind die auch 15 Jahre vorne dran und der Trend der Zukunft ist Java
Das wäre natürlich, wird mir nicht so gefallen, aber man weiß ja nie
Aber wir müssen mal gucken, also 90% der Sachen mit chinesischen Zeichen auf GitHub sind, ist Java
Okay C++, ich habe nichts gesagt, aber das meiste ist Java
China Zeug, okay Java Skript, zählt nicht, Java das hatten wir aber schon
Die haben eine Brille auf, genau weil sie nicht C Sharp können, oder ist so alt und schlecht eigentlich
Ruby ist auch erstaunlich, dass es noch so weit oben ist, aber das liegt wahrscheinlich an den 30 Milliarden Ruby Projekten, die auf GitHub erstellt wurden und keiner mehr pflegt
Go, okay verstehe ich, C++ bin ich nicht so scharf drauf, aber gerade Java, ich glaube das liegt zum größten Teil mit an den Chinesen, dass so viel neues Zeug in Java aus China kommt
Ich stehe hier auf Schmerzen, ja, tja, End of Function Zero, ich glaube, dass Java und C Sharp in Zukunft durch nix ersetzt werden
Ich glaube eher, dass es umgedreht ist, dass Sachen in Java und C Sharp eher die Sachen sind, die was anderes ersetzen werden
C++ ist ja komplette Qual mittlerweile, die einzigen Leute, die C++, ich will nicht mal sagen gerne machen, ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendjemand auf der Welt gibt,
der wirklich C++ gerne macht, vielleicht der ein oder andere Competitive Programmer oder so, aber es wird nicht so viel geben, die C++ gerne machen
Die einzigen, die C++ tagtäglich noch machen müssen aktuell, sind zum größten Teil Spieleprogrammierer und selbst da dank Unity ist immer mehr C Sharp am Start
Ist C++ losing popularity, ja, zum Glück, zum Glück, es ist ja auch absolut eklig
Also C Sharp ist garantiert nicht am sterben, C Sharp geht durch die Decke im Vergleich zu früher
Also da muss man das Microsoft mal zugute halten, dass die, ihr komplettes oder nicht komplettes, dass 90%.NET Core und C Sharp und alle Sachen, die sie machen, open sourced haben
War eine sehr gute Idee, seitdem, die letzten 4-5 Jahre geht C Sharp steil nach oben
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo Microsoft, wo Microsoft Github gekauft hat, das ist ja erst 2 Jahre ungefähr her, da haben so viele Leute Panik geschoben
So nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott, Microsoft kauft Github, wir müssen alle unsere Projekte von Github abziehen
Und jetzt sind ein paar Leute, sind nach GitLab, sind zu GitLab rüber und haben keine Contributors mehr
Habe ich auch gedacht, Leute, einfach mal nicht so viel Panik schieben und abwarten
Max, wirst du bald wieder Vollzeit arbeiten? Nö, warum sollte ich das denn machen?
Go hat bald Generics, habe ich auch gelesen, ja, aber das erzählen sie seit 5 Jahren schon
Nee, nee, also ich gehe nicht wieder Vollzeit arbeiten, gar kein Fall
Wenn schon, gehe ich eher weniger arbeiten, bevor ich wieder Vollzeit arbeiten gehe
Also die Chancen, dass ich 3 Tage die Woche arbeite, von 4, anstatt wieder 5 Tage von 4, das ist dann größer
Der Depp 1899 ist das Geburtsjahr, ok, das war schlecht, das war Payne's Champ, Payne's Champ, Witz, ich gebe es zu
Ich finde bloß gerade das passende Emote nicht, wo ist man, wo ist man, ah hier ist er, da ist er, Payne's Champ
Sagt ihm, er hat Open Source den Arsch gerettet, ja, wenn man es mal so will, im Prinzip rettet mir das auch tagtäglich den Arsch
Ich verwende auf der Arbeit den ganzen Tag Manjaro mit i3 WM und zum größten Teil Open Source Zeug
Das einzige, was ich regelmäßig verwenden muss, was nicht Open Source ist, ist halt Remote Winners Desktop mit Outlook drauf
Das war's
Was machst du in deiner Freizeit, wenn du gerade nicht streamst?
Ich überlege mir, was ich streamen könnte für Themen und ich überlege mir, ob ich mal wieder ein Video mache
Ansonsten programmiere ich ab und zu Offstream oder bin Sachen am Spielen
In letzter Zeit mache ich tatsächlich ab und zu mal Sport
Es gibt Sachen, ich weiß, das klaut mir keiner, aber langsam aber sicher muss das mal sein
Ich arbeite weiter an meiner Liste, warum C++ die schlechteste Programmiersprache ist
Da kommen täglich neue Punkte dazu
Nee, so schlimm ist es auch nicht
Ja, das war's
Und ich hätte ja gerne mal wieder den MMO, was ich richtig durchsuchten kann
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es für euch gar nicht so gut, weil wenn ich irgendeinen MMO hätte, was ich durchsuchten kann, würde ich weniger streamen
Video machen habe ich ja eh schon komplett eingestellt in letzter Zeit
Wow, Classic, nee, nee, nee, nee
Ist die Liste Open Source? Welche Liste?
Welche Liste?
Wie sieht es mit Familienplanung aus?
Gar nicht, soll ich da planen?
Ich plane, dass ich nichts plane
Ich plane auch, dass ich hoffentlich nichts planen muss
Also mit Kinder kannst du, nee, nee, nee
Also erstens, für Kinder brauchst du zwei Leute
Und drittens, ich mag keine Menschen und ich mag schon vor allem gar keine Kinder
Okay, vielleicht jetzt meine eigenen werden, vielleicht wäre das dann nicht so schlimm
Aber ich hab da überhaupt keinen Bock
Ach, sind wir jetzt überlegt, was das kostet?
Ist ja nicht nur stressig, es ist auch noch teuer
Nee, nee, nee, hör mal auf, das muss nicht sein
Ich meine, ich stehe jetzt ganz gut da
Ich hab zwei bis drei Einnahmequellen
Ich hab ganz gut Geld gespart, ich hab ein Haus
Warum sollte ich jetzt Kinder kriegen und alles wieder in den Sand setzen, was ich an Kohle am Start hab?
Das wäre ja komplett bescheuer
Ich meine, klar, sowas kann immer mal schnell sich ändern
Man weiß ja nie, was in Zukunft passiert
Aber ich hab's nicht vor
Wirklich nicht
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, Dapp 18,99, wahrscheinlich ist es sogar noch relativ wenig, was das kostet
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel teurer
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Mindeste, was du machen musst, dass das überlebt bist zum 18. Jahr
Wenn du willst, dass das eine gute Bildung, gute Ausbildung, auch mal die ein oder anderen Sachen erlebt
Und dass es dem Kind an sich gut geht und das auch was hatte, dann ist es wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Ecke mehr
Und das würde ich dann auch machen, wenn es soweit wäre, aber ich will gar nicht, dass es soweit kommt
Ja, aktuell ist das, Nico, das stimmt schon, aktuell
Also ich bin niemand, der hier der große Investor-Guru ist
BWL-Wirtschaftsteuisch ist nicht mein Fall
Aber aktuell ist es mit Anlegen, finde ich, gar nicht so einfach
Also so klassische Sachen anlegen kannst du ja nicht, es gibt ja für nix hinten
Du kannst ja im Endeffekt eh nur Aktien, ETFs oder sonst was kaufen, aber ich hab keinen Plastenschimmer davon
Ich bin zwar der krasse Hacker-Man, aber von sowas hab ich keine Ahnung
Oh, Airworker hat das neue Emote erkannt
Hier, wir haben ein neues Emote, TooSmartFFZ
Äh, TooSmart
Äh, warum findet ihr das nicht?
Too Intelligent, nein
Emotes, Public Library
Auf, mach hin, die Seite ist wieder exzellent schnell
Man muss nur wissen, was man tut, ja, das ist bei vielen Sachen so
TooSmart
Ah, yes
Was?
Ah, das ist BetterTwitchTV
Das ist BetterTwitchTV-Emote, das ist gar kein FFZ-Emote
Top-Emote, Shared-Emote, TooSmart
Exzellent, da ist es
Das brauchen wir noch, guck mal, da sind wir
TooSmart, das brauchen wir hier noch, ganz, ganz wichtig
Äh
What?
Was war denn das? Warum hat es gerade geleckt?
Warum hat es geleckt beim Downloaden?
Denn mein Browser ist gefriest beim Downloaden, was ist das denn?
TooSmart, so hier, exzellent
Ah, yes
Ah, das passt doch gut
Das gefällt mir, das hat was
Äh, Patrick, ich glaube, das hatte ich mir sogar schon mal angeguckt
Also, das ist eine Sache, die mir in Go echt fehlt
Go-Generics ist huge, das hätten sie schon vor 5 Jahren machen sollen
Hab gehört, dass Wirecard-Aktien gerade gut laufen
Was ist, was, ich hab das null verfolgt, ich hab nur auf Twitter gesehen, dass das trendet
Was ist da eigentlich los?
Was, was ist Wirecard? Wirecard
Was ist Wirecard?
German Payment Processor, ist das sowas wie PayPal oder so?
Warum benutzt du verschiedene Browser?
Ähm, ja hauptsächlich verwende ich eigentlich Chromium
Ansonsten verwende ich verschiedene Browser, weil verschiedene Browser verschiedene Dinge anders machen, teilweise
Seiten anders rendern, gerade Firefox und Chrome sollte man immer mal vergleichen, weil man Web-Anwendungen macht
Gut, und dass ich jetzt Vivaldi, Chrom, Chromium, Edge und Gedöns drauf hab, hat sich halt einfach so ergeben
Zum größten Teil verwende ich Chromium
Denen wird Bilanzfälschung vorgeworfen, haben eine KPMG Prüfung nach der anderen
Was ist denn KPMG?
Internet, ist...
Ah, Stonks, verstehe
Irgendwie sind da 1,9 Millionen, was, nur Millionen?
Ah, Milliarden, ah, exellent
Ich wollte gerade sagen, für 1,9 Millionen steht da doch keiner auf
Was sind da, was sind da 1,9 Millionen?
Das hat Montana Black in Rolex-Uren, dafür steht doch da kein Mensch auf, 1,9 Millionen, 1,9 Milliarden ist was anderes
Stonks
Guck mal, wir haben so einen Stonks-Emote
Das machen wir, das fügen wir hinzu
Das brauchen wir als Emote, Leute, ich hab ja...
Mal gucken, ob's geht
Stonks
Noch nicht, aber ich hab's hinzugefügt, bald sollte das Emote funktionieren
Spätestens nächsten Stream soll's funktionieren
Ähm...
Gab's hier noch irgendwelche Sachen?
Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so lange, auch nicht
Spätestens 13 Uhr ist Mittagessen da
Mal gucken, blablabla
Fährst du mittags immer heim? Nee, nee, nee, nee
Mach ich nicht
Aktuell ist kein Problem, aktuell ist eh 100% Homeoffice
Da muss ich gar nicht heimfahren
FFZ Autocompletion
Generell, Leute, wer nicht FFZ installiert hat, das ist das beste Addon, was es für Twitch gibt
Du hast Autocompletion für Emotes, du hast ne History im Chat
Das ist das beste Emote, was es gibt
Addon, Emote, was auch immer
Es kann Better Twitch TV Emotes und FFZ Emotes
Also, excellent, besser als Better Twitch TV ist es
Beste, beste Twitch Enhancement Extension
Captain Peng schreibt seine Betriebssystemklausel
Ach, Berufsschule, Berufsschule, komm her, Berufsschule ist ja nur wirklich
Also Berufsschule ist ja kein Ding
Berufsschule machst du ohne zu lernen
Ich kann mich auch dran erinnern
Wir haben, ich glaube das war auch nur Betriebssystem, Betriebssysteme, Arbeit in der Berufsschule
Haben wir geschrieben
Und, also wie gesagt, ich hab ja für die Berufsschule prinzipiell nichts gelernt
Außer ab und zu mal ein bisschen für Wirtschaftssachen, weil mir das überhaupt nicht liegt
Und ich kann mich auch dran erinnern, wir haben die Arbeit gekriegt, das waren zwei Seiten
Die waren, meiner Ansicht nach waren die, waren die wirklich
Und ich hab einfach überall was eingetragen, so kurz wie es ging
Hab nach einer halben Stunde ab, war ich fertig, hab so um mich geguckt
Alle, alle am Da, sind so wild am Schreiben, wild am Schreiben, wild am Schreiben
Und ich so okay, also entweder lese ich es mir jetzt nochmal durch oder ich gebe es einfach ab
Da kommt scheiß drauf, ich will mich damit nicht länger beschäftigen, also ich gebe es einfach ab
Und eins, easy
Also Berufsschule ist von Arsch, Berufsschule ist einfach
Trotzdem hatten wir Leute, die haben es geschafft, 6er zu schreiben in der Berufsschule
Ich hab euch ja schon ein paar Mal von dem erzählt, das geschafft hat, 2 von 100 Punkten in der Datenbankarbeit zu bekommen
Weil er zweimal CREATE TABLE geschrieben hat
Und das muss er erstmal schaffen, nicht 0 von 100, 0 von 100 verstehe ich, aber 2 von 100 ist wirklich Painz Champ
Das Chat durchgucken, ne ich hab alles beantwortet, exellent
Ach Betriebssystem an der Uni, okay das war was anderes, das ist wahrscheinlich dann doch bisschen schwieriger
Wo bloß, was hältst du, choose my name fragt, was hältst du, wobei ich kann das eigentlich einblenden, was er sagt
Wo hab ich den Chat, da
Was hältst du denn von dem Vorschlag unserer Familienministerium, dass man Vorratsdaten speichert für den Kampf gegen Kindermissbrauch
Wenn es den Leuten wirklich um den Kampf von Kindesmissbrauch gehen würde, dann würde ich ja sagen, okay
Kann man da mal drüber diskutieren, leider werden solche Sachen immer vorgeschoben, um es aus anderen Beweggründen einzuführen
Und das finde ich, gerade das finde ich in dem Kontext schlecht
Und den Hang dazu, alles weitere noch mehr zu überwachen und das Ganze noch lascher zu machen entgegen dem, was die Bevölkerung eigentlich haben möchte
Da muss ich halt mal wieder das Bundesverfassungsgericht mit beschäftigen und sagen, gibt's nicht
Ich hab letztens eine Statistik gesehen, um wie viele neue Gesetze und Sachen sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht kümmern muss
Und man hat gesehen, seit 2005 oder so in dem Dreh ist das krass angestiegen, also sprich, die Gesetze müssen mittlerweile so dermaßen schlecht sein
Dass sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht mit so vielen Gesetzen beschäftigen muss wie noch nie und es gibt immer mehr
Also die Qualität der Gesetzgebung ist wohl nicht der Wahnsinn die letzten Jahre gewesen, wenn man sich die Statistik so anguckt
Ich muss mal suchen, ob ich das finde
Ist ja wirklich gut, dass er 2005 hatte, ging das da oben
Stonks, yes
Ahoy aus der Ikea Schlange, exzellent
Mittwoch Flugzeugball, Freitags BWL Logistik und die Woche darauf Flugantriebe, RIP
Das klingt nach Big Brain Studium
Ja stimmt, hast du die Maske auf
Ich hab übrigens meine Maske immer noch nicht
Ich glaub ich hab irgendwas von Cosplay geschrieben
Genau, Metro Cosplay
Ich hab meine Maske immer noch nicht verwendet für irgendwas
Jetzt hab ich die am Start und ich hab sie während der ganzen Corona Zeit nicht einmal verwendet
Noch kein Metro Cosplay nähe
Hat er das gesagt, Shoes by Name
Ja, immer noch alle Filter verpackt, sonst war's
Für nix verwendet bisher
Ja wir wollen noch mal kurz gucken, was für heute Abend prophezeit wird bei der Apple Event
Also iOS 14, da geh ich ganz fest voraus
Mac OS 10.16 juckt mich ehrlich gesagt null
Wäre aber nur logisch, dass auch eine neue Mac OS Version kommt
Den geht langsam die Namen aus glaube ich
Es kommt als nächstes
Apple hat ja gerne irgendwelche Landschaftsdinger
Streamst du das Event? Ja, 19 Uhr
Also ich hoffe man darf das Restreamen, aber ich hab das letztes Jahr auch gemacht
Und das hat keinen interessiert
Software Rumors
Watch OS 7, ist mir vollkommen egal
TV OS 14 ist mir vollkommen wurscht
Ja das mit Arm erwarte ich eigentlich auch Patrick
Frag mich warum hier gar nix drinne steht
Schlechte Predictions
Ja also das mit Arm ist nahezu sicher, dass das kommt
Mal ganz ohne Applaus und sowas, das ist ja ohne Publikum
Ja mal gespannt, mal gespannt was da rauskommt
Also heute ist das, ich glaube 19 Uhr
Ja genau 19 Uhr
Ja ja wir stimmen alles zu
19 Uhr
M-E-S-Z
Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass das mit Zeitzonen an sich schon vollkommen wir ist
Jetzt werden Zeitzonen auch noch in unterschiedlichen Sprachen unterschiedlich abgekürzt
C-E-S-T hast du, das ist Central Europe Summer Time
Und das ist Mitteleuropäische Sommerzeit
Das ist so hardcore pepega diese ganze Zeitzonen Geschichte
Da weiß ich echt nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
Das schlimmste ist für Leute, die irgendwelche Daytime Libraries programmieren müssen, die haben vollkommen gelitten
Ich habe euch doch schonmal die Story erzählt, dass Schweden den 30. Februar hatte, oder?
Weil Schweden wollte ihr Kalendersystem umstellen, also das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, keine Ahnung, 60 oder noch was oder so
Schweden wollte irgendwie ihren Kalender umstellen
Oder vielleicht, ich glaube sogar ein bisschen später war es
Und Schweden hat es verkackt den Kalender umzustellen
Und weil sie Griech geführt haben in der Zeit, haben sie gesagt, ah nee jetzt können wir jetzt keinen Kalender umstellen
Und dann ist ihnen danach wieder eingefallen, oh fuck wir wollten den Kalender umstellen
Ah ja gut, dass wir jetzt aufholen, machen wir einfach mal den 30. Februar
Deswegen war Schweden glaube ich das einzige Land auf der Welt, was jemals den 30. Februar hatte
Ja, 1712
Die Schweden, ja
Die Schweden, guckt es euch an, die haben echt, haben es verkackt, ja
Heute ist hier Big Brain Stream, ihr lernt mal wieder was
Können wir Monka Gunn durch Monka Shoot ersetzen, was ist denn Monka Shoot?
Ist doch genau das gleiche
Achso, ah da schießt, nee wir haben schon zu viel animierte Gifts
Gibt es kein Dean für Zeitzonen? Es gibt Iso, Iso gibt es für Zeitzonen
Und ähm, UTF, nee nicht UTF, äh und wie heißt es?
UTC, nicht UTF, UTC, fast
Ja, was so ein paar Buchstaben Unterschied machen können
Wie findest du Arm? Für mich war das ein Grund, weshalb ich mir das neue Surface Pro nicht geholt habe
Mir ist die Architektur unter der Plattform eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, solang es die Software gibt, die ich haben will
Was interessiert mich als normale Anwendung, ob das ein X6, 8, Arm oder sonst was ist?
Wenn es natürlich dazu führt, dass die Software, die ich haben will, nicht drauf läuft, dann find ich kacke
Kennst du das Video? Nee, das kenn ich noch nicht, aber ich kenn von irgendeiner Entwicklerkonferenz einen Vortrag zu dem Thema
Wo es um Daytime Libraries geht und wo er das halt auch erzählt hat, dass die Schweden den 30. Februar hatten
Ich hab euch eigentlich erzählt, ich hab gestern Abend eine Mail bekommen, wohlgemerkt, add Wupplors und nicht add Max FPS
Also explizit Anschrift für meinen Twitch-Stream, also jemand, der nicht über YouTube drauf gekommen ist, sondern über den Twitch-Stream
Und ich hab ein Angebot bekommen, also ich hab ein Angebot bekommen, also ich hab ein Angebot bekommen, also ich hab ein Angebot bekommen, also ich hab ein Angebot bekommen
Sondern über den Twitch-Stream und ich hab ein Angebot bekommen für, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, Raid Shadow Legends
Raid Shadow Legends, ungefähr 500 Dollar, also aufgerundet, 483 oder irgendwie sowas haben sie geschrieben, ungefähr 500 Dollar für Advertisements
Ich hab aber keine Ahnung, was die wollen, also was die, was die wollen, dass ich, dass ich mache und außerdem hab ich keinen Bock mit denen was zu machen
Das mach ich nicht
Ich fand's, ich fand's aber cool, dass ich wirklich mal add, add Wupplors was gekriegt hab
Ich lass mir so, ne ne ne ich mach kein Raid Shadow Legends Advertisement
Kein Fall, kack Game
Angeblich haben die ja in ihrem Vertrag drinne stehen, dass man enthousiastisch das Game anpreisen muss
Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, hey Jungs, also hier Raid Shadow Legends Mobile Game, wer's mal bock hat ausprobieren
Probiert mal aus
Nein, die wollen von dir, dass du sagst, Leute ich hab hier dieses geile Mobile Game entdeckt, lass mich mal an
Raid Shadow Legends, das ist ein, ein Fantasy RPG, Cross-Platform, Mobile, das gibt's sogar für den PC
Oh mein Gott, was man in diesem Game alles machen kann, ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie geil das ist, wir gucken uns das Ganze jetzt
Also das wollen die ungefähr, dass man das so macht
Also wenn ihr Leute auf YouTube gesehen habt, die das so oder so ähnlich machen, dann haben die den gleichen Vertrag unterschrieben, den alle kriegen bei Raid Shadow Legends
Da steht unter anderem drinne, man soll das, hypen das Game
Oder enthousiastisch soll man, enthousiastik soll man das vorlesen
Excellent
Ist das nicht mega der Müll, ja das ist Hardcore Müll das Game, schlimmer als Windows
Das ist totaler Craft of Raid Shadow Legends
Achja und die wollen auch, dass man bei dem, äh, Edward, also bei der Werbung, die man macht, dass man sagt, oh diese Spiele erinnern mich so sehr an gute alte Rollenspiele, endlich gibt sowas jetzt auch für Mobile
Das ist kein Witz, kein Witz, sowas in der Richtung soll man da sagen
Kennt ihr noch den Coin Master?
Erinnert sich noch jemand an den, sogar Bibi spielt den Coin Master
Oder ist der Coin Master, alter
Der Coin Master, Mensch
Wie siehts da eigentlich aus, Coin Master, Android Store, was hat das aktuell so für Bewertung
Warum hat diese scheiß Game, viereinhalb Sterne
Achso, ja ich weiß, weil die Leute umsonst In-Game-Währung kriegen für positive Bewertung
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich glaube das ist verboten, aber juck Google nicht
Ich bin mal ziemlich sicher, dass es verboten ist, äh, quasi Store-Wertung zu kaufen
Der Coin Master, jaja, guck mal da hier, excellent Game, viereinhalb Sterne
We are sorry to hear you are not enjoying our experience
Das ist ein absoluter Bullshit Unding-Marketing-Satz
Was genau soll dieser Satz sagen, ok, es tut uns, also Kimberly es tut uns leid
Äh, zu hören, es tut uns leid, es tut uns leid, es tut uns leid, es tut uns leid
Es tut uns leid, es tut uns leid, es tut uns leid
Es tut uns, also Kimberly es tut uns leid, äh, zu hören, dass du hier nicht unsere Erfahrung, äh, dass du nicht Spaß an unsere Erfahrung
Was, wie will man das überhaupt, was ist das überhaupt für ein Satz
Hätten die geschrieben an Schatz Experience einfach, you are not enjoying our game
Da wär es ja ok gewesen, aber dieses ganze Experience-Gelaber da immer
Wo hat es eigentlich, wo hat es eigentlich die guten Bewertungen her
Wo hatten das Game die guten Bewertungen her
Also für mich sehen die Bewertungen jetzt nicht so gut aus, und ehrlich bin, ne
Was, time in life, life
Ja, alles klar, wenn man daheim ist, weil man krank ist, ist natürlich das beste was man spielen kann, Coin Master natürlich, was sonst
Und Pietro Lombardi für Coin Master bekommen haben
Ok, Pietro Lombardi, ja, keine Ahnung, ob das irgendjemand für den Menschen auch interessiert
Wahrscheinlich hat der jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel dafür bekommen, aber für solche Sachen gibt's eh relativ viel
Dieter Bohlen hat sicherlich massenhaft bekommen
Ähm, was mich aber viel eher interessieren würde, ist was Ninja für den Wechsel zu Mixer bekommen hat
Das ist eigentlich die Sache, die mich interessiert
Coin Master, was Bibi und so von Coin Master entgekriegt haben, juckt mich nicht
Mich würde interessieren, was Ninja für Mixer bekommen hat
Weil ich bin mir nach wie vor ziemlich sicher, dass Ninja das, äh, quasi der hauptsächliche Grund bei Ninja war, dass er ausgesorgt hat danach
So nach dem Motto, das war der Deal für die Rente im Endeffekt
So nach dem Motto, ich mach das jetzt und egal was passiert, ich muss nun wieder arbeiten gehen
Ich würde, witzet, das wird mich echt, das wird mich echt interessieren
Ich kann das unglaublich schwer schätzen, was, was jetzt so jemand wie Ninja bekommt für den Wechsel
Der hat davor schon ausgesorgt gehabt, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher
Ähm, aber spätestens nach dem Deal
Man möchte ja vielleicht auch einen gewissen, äh, Standard halten, ja, und dafür ist so ein Deal über ein paar Millionen sicherlich nicht verkehrt
Naja
Gibt's denn, gibt's, gibt's, was ist denn heute so in der IT-Welt passiert?
Gibt's denn irgendwas spannendes, was man wissen muss?
Wie rassistisch sind unsere Algorithmen?
Oh ja, das hab ich mich schon immer gefragt
Jupp, mich überhaupt nicht
Die Bugs und das drohende Zwangsupdate, okay
Warum drückt der eigentlich auf Windows 10 drauf?
Was, was ist der Sinn von auf Windows 10 drauf drücken mit dem Finger?
Da müsste man mal Anton Wattmann fragen
Vielleicht versucht der Windows auch rauszudrücken aus seinem Rechner
Ja, aber selbst wenn das Touch ist, an die Stelle zu touchen macht überhaupt nichts
Ich muss übrigens demnächst auch updaten
Thunderbolt, ja
Habt ihr den riesen Shitstorm um The Last of Us 2 mitgekriegt?
Die Leute sind voll am eskalieren
Gerade
Wieder mal
Kann ich verstehen
Diesmal versteh ich und wisst ihr was ich cool finde?
Dass die Leute mal ausnahmsweise, äh, nicht wegen irgendwelchen Sinnbedürfnissen, äh, nicht wegen irgendwelchen Sinnbedürfnissen, äh, nicht wegen irgendwelchen Sinnbedürfnissen, äh, nicht wegen irgendwelchen Sinnbedürfnissen, äh
Ausnahmsweise, äh, nicht wegen irgendwelchen sinnlosen Sachen eskalieren, sondern, äh, weil, weil das wirklich fragwürdige Storyentscheidungen hat
Ich sag jetzt nichts, also ich werd euch nicht spoilern
Ähm, das hat wirklich sehr merkwürdige Entscheidungen, wo ich mich frage, hä, was ist, warum hat Naughty Dog so komische Dinger gemacht?
Ich spoil euch nicht, nee, nee, keine Sorge
Ähm
Es gab natürlich auch wieder Leute, das fand ich besonders geil
Es gab ja auch, es gab ja auch wieder Leute, die gesagt haben, nee, nee, nee, nee
Storymäßig ist das alles okay
Alle Leute, die das Spiel schlecht finden, sind nur homophob
Beste Begründung überhaupt
Die Leute reden sich über die Story auf
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das kann nicht sein
Ähm, aber
Ich, ich hab mir Let's Play angeguckt
Und, also nicht komplett, so die wichtigsten Sachen
Und ich muss sagen, ich fand die Story auch echt merkwürdig, was sie da getrieben haben
Also ich werd's nicht spielen
Oh
Excellent
Pearl 5.32
Da hab ich ja drauf gewartet, endlich
Right only
Vielleicht schreiben die was Sinnvolles, was, was, äh, erwartet wird
Was wir vom, okay, was wir erwarten
Also, zeig mal her
Nee, nee, ich, äh, Deadlift, ich erzähl hier nichts im Stream
Das Spiel ist noch zu neu und viele wollen das noch spielen
Das haben wir schon gesagt, das wird heute erwartet
Da geh ich auch fest von aus
Arm, da bin ich auch ganz fest dabei, dass das kommt
Plüsselfinder
Airtags
Das Zeug
Juckt mich, juckt mich nicht
IT-Produkt-Manager
Stonks
Auch guck mal, es gibt einen neuen Grafiktreiber für Respirator
Das ist nicht schlecht
Ja, irgendwie nicht so spannend, ne, was, was, was heute, was da heute am Start ist
Ich hab übrigens meine VM gar nicht an, fällt mir grad auf
Das überseh ich im Zweifelsfall noch irgendwas
Abgerade Apple-Werbung
Ja, gerade heute muss Apple viel Werbung machen
Oh
O
Och
Ah 5 Follower alles klar, lull Moment, es gibt WWDC als Kategorie auf Twitch,
sehe ich das richtig?
Es gibt eine offizielle Kategorie für das Event, ok, can co-stream WWDC, da bin ich
ja mal gespannt.
Oh, MonkaS, aber ich habe letztes Jahr auch gestreamt und es hat keinen interessiert.
Und ich gehe auch mal stark von außen, es interessiert keinen.
Youtube, ja, nee, Apple, Youtube, wo gibt es denn das heute Abend?
Apple bestimmt hier, ja, hier, bin ich eigentlich, ok ich weiß, wenn
man so die Frage stellt, dann erwarte ich, dass man sagt, nee, aber bin ich der einzige,
der die Apple-Avatare übelst, nicht hässlich, aber so, so unpassend ist auch nicht das
richtige Wort, eben so billig findet, billig, ich finde die sehen übelst billig aus.
So richtig, so richtig low, wie als hätte es irgendeinen, irgendeinen, irgendeinen
Blender-Tutorial-Typ gemacht, ich finde die übelst hässlich, billig finde ich die, billig
sehen die aus, die Apple-Avatare, wie Avatar-Apple, die Xbox 360-Avatare, ja, gibt es denn eigentlich
noch einen, Xbox Informatikor, warte mal, das bin ich nicht, Xbox Profile, kann man
danach suchen, wie sucht man nach Xbox Live Leute, Xbox Live Profile Search, geht das?
Ich wollte mir eigentlich mal einen Xbox Avatar mal angucken, wie der aussieht, kann man
den Tag Search, geht das? Das ist eine Scam-Seite, 100 Pro. Okay, ich blicke da nicht durch beide
Microsoft-Geschichten, der Windows 10 Xbox App, ja, dass man das schon mal nicht öffentlich
verlinken kann, ist schon wieder richtig, richtig Hardcore-Fail, ne? Ach ja, krieg langsam,
krieg ich Hunger, ich muss doch kurz was trinken. Ja, die Xbox 360-Avatare, die waren cool und
mit der Xbox One haben sie es voll verkackt, da gab es die Avatare noch im dritten Untermenü,
vom dritten Untermenü und es hat sich keiner mehr für interessiert. Die Sachen waren richtig
cool auf der 360, weil du auch in Spielen Sachen frei spielen konntest. Ich hatte dann,
ich weiß, ich hatte mit meinem Avatar hatte ich das Super Meat Boy-T-Shirt an und so
einen Left 4 Dead-Midipack und das fand ich richtig nice, dass das so integriert war.
As mit, oh nee, please, hör auf. Lass mal hier ausmachen. So, tja, gibt es noch irgendwelche
Sachen? Ich hab jetzt logischerweise, nachdem es quasi Mittagspause und Stream ist, ich
hab mir jetzt nichts Großartiges überlegt, gibt es heute irgendwas Neues auf Hacker-News
oder so. Arm, Mac, Impact und Intel, ziemlich groß. Engine XUI, ok, das klingt nicht schlecht.
Aber da kann man doch anscheinend gar nichts machen drin. Na super, das ist eine Webseite
mit einem Text-Editor drauf, das brauch ich auch nicht. Wozu ist das denn, das ist ja
komplett sinnlos. Moin, X Jellermann, exzellent. Ich hab gar kein Winke-E-Mode, fällt mir
gerade auf, nix. X zum Winken, aber wozu braucht man denn Winke-E-Mode, wenn man Coggers
hat? Browse, Browsers, was? Browse Service. Browse Modern Web on Historical Browsers,
ok, exzellent. Wo ist die Demo? Oh, Internet Explorer 5, jawoll. Wo ist die Demo? Demo,
keine Demo, da guckt man sonst nicht an. WireGuard ist jetzt in der OpenBSD drin,
das ist cool. Oh, heute ist ja nix passiert, es ist ja absolut Residenz-Liefer hier. Ist
ja nix los. Das wird ganz kurzer Stream, ja, wie gesagt nur Mittagspause Stream, spätestens
13 Uhr wenn das Essen kommt, das ist vorbei. Es ist ja heute nichts passiert, ist ja mega
langweilig. Hat jemand einen Tipp für ein RSS Feed Programm? Nö. Ich glaube ich hab
die letzten 10 Jahre keine RSS Feeds mehr benutzt. Rico, wie darf man sich das eigentlich
vorstellen? Rico sagt, ich hab's ja grad weggeklickt im Chat, hast du mitbekommen,
dass MeToo jetzt auch auf Twitch ist? Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Machen jetzt
Leute Streams, wo sie erklären, wie sie Frauen schon belästigt haben oder was? Allein schon,
dass man defaultmäßig davon ausgeht, dass jeder Mann irgendwie Frauen schon mal belästigt
hat, ist doch schon mal beknackt. Ich wette mit euch die meisten Männer haben noch nie
Frauen belästigt, warum sollten sie das auch machen? Ich will gar nicht wissen, dass das
jetzt auf Twitch ist oder nicht. Die Themen, die umschiffig war einfach. Kannste nur verlieren.
Wir kümmern uns lieber um Big Brain Themen. Exzellent. Guck mal, das ist Fasken, das
ist ja richtig gut, man kann relativ gut umschalten von hier zu hier. Also ich kann jetzt demnächst
sagen im Stream so nach dem Motto richtig hier Big Brain Idee und dann kann ich umschalten
auf. Exzellent. Ach so ist das Nico, ok. Ja das finde ich natürlich nicht gut, aber
die einfachste Variante da drauf zu reagieren ist Bannen. Natürlich wäre es schön, wenn
sich auf Twitch oder auf Twitter oder auf YouTube keiner mehr gegenseitig beleidigen
würde, aber nachdem das nicht vorkommen wird, das einfachste ist einfach alles Bannen, was
dir auf den Sack geht. Enrico, das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht anders, da explodiert mein
Gehirn wieder. Es gibt noch so viel Sachen, die ich ertrage am Tag, was diese Themen angeht.
Ne ne, ich schaue mir das jetzt nicht an. Es gibt so paar Themen, da mache ich in letzter
Zeit einen Bogen drum. Wisst ihr, früher, da habe ich immer noch so den Hang dazu gehabt,
alles was irgendwie einer verlinkt hat, ich meine jetzt nicht Rico explizit dich, so allgemein,
alle Links die man gekriegt hat und egal wo man schon wusste was der Content war, habe
ich früher immer angeklickt, so nach dem Motto, was ist da dahinter, lass mal her und
heute mache ich so, wenn ich weiß, schon ungefähr was hinter dem Link sein könnte, manchmal
sage ich ganz bewusst, ne das gebe ich mir heute nicht. Sei es jetzt die üblichen Diskussionen,
die es auf Twitter gibt oder auch wenn Leute irgendwelche Videos posten, posten, wo ich
im Vorfeld schon weiß, das ist abartig, wenn man sich das anguckt. Also du musst ja heute
im Internet nicht lange suchen, dass du Videos findest von Leuten, mit denen der Kopf platzt,
um es jetzt mal extrem zu sagen. Und wenn ich so einen Link irgendwie sehe oder wenn
er irgendwo gepostet wäre und ich weiß schon, was da dahinter sein könnte, denke ich, muss
ich mir heute nicht geben, ich klicke nicht mehr alle Links an. Ihr könnt mich mit Links
übrigens nicht debaten, weil ich habe einen Preview Plugin, was mir die Seite quasi ohne
Java Skript zuzuladen previewed, bevor ich sie aufmache, also keine Chance.
Einfach zu BigBrain, ja. Ne, ne, ne, das Thema diskutieren wir jetzt nicht im Stream, da
habe ich heute echt keinen Bock drauf. Ich bin immer begeistert, wie viele Leute die
iPhones haben Siri verwenden. Ich habe zwei iPhones, ich habe noch ein altes iPhone 6,
das ich verwende, mobile und noch ein iPhone, was ist das, SXXXS oder was auch immer, wo
keine SIM-Karte drin ist und auf keinem der Geräte habe ich Siri aktiviert. Siri get
out. Direkt deaktiviert, ja. Ich glaube, eine der wenigen sinnvollen Sachen wo ich Siri verwenden
würde ist, wenn ich, keine Ahnung, beim Leute Auto fahren oder irgendwas, also sprich, wenn
man die Hände nicht frei hat und dann sagen möchte, ey, was weiß ich, wann ist mein nächster
Termin oder sowas oder anrufen oder das, das ist irgendwie sinnvoll, aber für die alltägliche
Bedienung tippe ich viel lieber auf dem Display. Das ist richtig Boomer. Kruste können wir
machen, die satten. Außer bei LMGs. Timer für die Pizza erstellen. Kannst du eigentlich
für nicht-ALTI-Menschen einen Browser empfehlen? Wie für nicht-ALTI-Menschen? Nicht-ALTI-Menschen
sollen einfach das verwenden, was jeder verwendet, Chrome oder Firefox. Könntest du einen Viewbots,
oh, das ist eine gute Frage, da kann ich mir meinen Senf zugeben, könntest du einen Viewbots
kippen, geht das überhaupt? Ja klar, funktioniert das. Das erste, wenn man sowas machen will
ist, man muss sich überlegen, wie werden Viewer gezählt. Das ist wahrscheinlich von Plattform
zu Plattform unterschiedlich. Also werden Viewer pro Procession gezählt, pro Browser
Tab, pro Verbindung, pro IP oder sonst was. Das ist das erste, was man sich überlegen
muss, sprich, um einen Viewbots zu kreieren, wie zählt die jeweilige Seite Views? Ich
vermute mal, dass es Twitch pro Verbindung macht, weil wenn ich mehrere Tabs aufmache
auf dem Stream, der keine Zuschauer hat, dann hat der danach mehr Zuschauer. Also ich vermute
mal, dass es pro Verbindung oder pro Session, pro Tab, oder wie auch immer, wird es wahrscheinlich
bei Twitch sein und dann ist es ziemlich einfach Viewbots zu programmieren. Also wenn es wirklich,
wenn das wirklich pro Session bzw. pro Tab ist, dann ist es einfach, aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass Twitch nicht blöde ist und das limitiert. Also dass Twitch so eine
doppelte Logik hat, so nach dem Motto, es wäre logisch, dass bis zu 10 Leuten pro Haushalt
quasi jetzt unterschiedliche Streams gucken auf unterschiedlichen Geräten und die das
trotzdem limitieren. Also wenn du quasi von einer IP ausgehend jetzt 500 mal den gleichen
Stream aufmachst, dass das dann, oder auch 500 unterschiedliche Streams, dass das Twitch
checkt und sagt, ne das kann nicht sein. Also die haben da bestimmt schon eine gewisse
Logik dahinter. Aber selbst, aber sagen wir mal so, sollte das nicht der Fall sein, dann
ist es total einfach. Dann ist die aller einfachste Sache, das sind 10 Zeilen Code, wäre es
ein Embedded Chrome zu nehmen oder ein Chrome Scripting Plugin, nicht Plugin, Chrome Scripting
Library und einfach in einem Headless Chrome 500 Tabs aufzumachen. Das braucht zwar RAM
und so, ist nicht die beste Variante dafür, das wäre aber ziemlich easy. Aber auch sehr
einfach festzustellen. Sollte das irgendwie bisschen Magic im Hintergrund haben mit Fingerprinting
und Absender-IPs oder sonstige Geschichten, dann muss man es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
komplizierter machen und im Zweifelsfall muss man das auch über irgendwelche Proxy-Server
machen oder VPNs, wobei VPNs ist schwierig, da hast du auch nicht unterschiedlich viele
IPs. Dann ist es einfach so, du gehst irgendwo hin und fragst irgendeinen krassen russischen
Hacker-Man, ob er dir Zugang zu seinen Bot-Nets gibt und machst darüber View-Bots. Das würde
dann tatsächlich das einfachste sein, anstatt sich selbst da irgendwas zu basteln. Es wird
vor allem auch gar nicht so billig. Also im Endeffekt müsste man, müsste man sich dann
jeweils ein paar Server mieten, die billigsten Server, da reicht ja aus, so eine 2 Dollar
im Monat VM, müsste man sich da ein paar mieten überall auf der Welt und gucken, wie viel
man maximal damit dann generieren kann pro IP. Da müsste man schon ein bisschen Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken. Aber ich denke mal, im kleinen Maßstab, so bis zu 400-500 Viewern, sollte
man das recht gut hinbekommen können, bis Twitch das Ganze rauskriegt. Bei richtig großen
Sachen, wo dann auf einen Schlag, keine Ahnung, 3-4.000 Viewer kommen oder so, dann sollte
doch sich lieber der russische Hacker-Man mit seinem Bot-Nets daran machen.
Ja, Stripes007, ich weiß, aber ist die Frage, bis zu wie viele Viewern das geht. Ich denke
mal, Twitch hat schon eine Logik. Also er schreibt hier, also mein Pi kann 4 Streams
öffnen und zählt auch bei jedem als Viewer. Ja, ich glaube Twitch hat schon irgendwo Limits,
wie viele Viewer von einer, von einer Sache ausgehen können.
Shizubi, du kannst davon ausgehen, da ist definitiv nicht safe. Viewbots zu detekten
ist ziemlich einfach, statistisch gesehen. Also wenn du auf einmal, also wenn du ein
Channel bist mit normalerweise 5 Viewer und du wirst nicht gehostet oder irgendwie sonstige
Shoutouts auf Twitter von großen Channels oder auf Twitch oder sonst was und du kriegst
aus dem Nichts auf einmal 500 Zuschauer, dann ist das verdammt offensichtlich Viewbot.
Da guckst du einfach, wo die ganzen IPs herkommen, ob es da verschiedene Muster in den Request
gibt und das kriegst du relativ einfach raus. Die Sache ist da nur die und das ist das,
was es schwierig macht. Und das ist was es schwierig macht. Most interesting number
compassion. Okay, das können wir uns gleich nochmal angucken. Und das ist was es schwierig
macht, was Viewbotting angeht. Du kannst den Channelbetreiber nicht bannen, so ohne weiteres,
weil der Channelbetreiber kann ja einfach geviewbottet werden, ohne dass er irgendwie
was für kann. Das kommt dir auch oft genug vor, dass die Leute sagen, hoch warum hab
ich auf einmal 500 Zuschauer, weil irgendjemand einen Viewbot angeschmissen hat. Du kannst
ihn ja nicht einfach bannen dafür, vielleicht kann er ja gar nichts dafür, das ist schwierig.
Haben diese Viewer auch alle einen Twitch-Account wahrscheinlich, nicht? Du brauchst ja keinen
Twitch-Account. Okay, most interesting numbers compassion. Das ist das, das klingt, das klingt
nach excellent big brain Video. Das ist das beste Emote, alter. Negative one, okay. Class
integer. Ja, ja. Wohlgemerkt unsigned, äh äh signed integer, nicht unsigned. Oh, jetzt
wird's aber big brain. Das ist, das ist, das ist zu high IQ für die Mittagspause. Excellent.
Das ist klar. The Gauss. Ah, yes.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Alles klar. Der Euler ist ganz schön oft dabei.
Da fehlt 69. Kommt noch 69? Gut, dass das drin ist, ist klar. Ah, wenigstens, wenigstens
ist der Kram drin. 420, da muss natürlich auch drin sein. Mama of the Beast. Warum,
ey, warum gibt's das Video? Die Sinnhaftigkeit des Videos hat sich jetzt nicht so ganz erschlossen,
aber das, das heißt ja nix, ne. Ja, äh, mal mal die Musik wieder anmachen. 1337 hat
gefehlt, ja. 360 Northscope natürlich auch. Gut geeignet für die Grundschule, excellent.
Ja, aber so viel zum Thema Viewbot. Ich glaub, da hab ich mich jetzt lange noch drüber ausgelassen.
Ha, exposed. Ja, guck, ich werf das an. Das ist übrigens verbugt, dieses, das Plugin für
die, ah, da ist überhaupt kein Hackerman dahinter gewesen. Tja. So, Apple Event, heute
Abend 19 Uhr geht's los. Bin echt gespannt drauf. Vor allem, ob man streamen darf. Ich
werd's einfach mal machen und gucken, was passiert. Programmierst du mal einen im Stream?
Ja, aber auf Mixer dann. Seit wann streamen die auf YouTube? Da haben die glaube ich letztes
Jahr auch schon gemacht. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob's wieder nen Monitorstand für, ob's hier
nen 1000 Dollar Monitorstand gibt. Announcement. Wo ist es? Das war das Highlight vor letztem.
Die haben ja sogar das Video gelöscht. Oder wollten, dass das Video gelöscht wird.
War ja klar, war ja klar, dass es dazu einen gibt, ey. Moment, Moment, der geht immer.
Moment, jetzt geht's lauter. Okay, das geht mir zu schnell. Also was, was, okay langsam.
Head Marketing Guy called me, okay.
Was macht das?
Du bist es!
Und du?
Was auch immer!
Ich habe die Mütze mit einer Paillette gefunden!
Und du?
Und ich habe sie gefunden, weil sie die Paillette mit einer Paillette mit einer Schusspumpe
und einer Schusspumpe.
Vor allem, vor allem an dem Monitor stand, gab es ja dieses Video von dem einen, der
sagte, dass die Schrauben abbrechen, ne?
Ernsthaft?
Ist auch gerade!
Oh man, das war klar, dass es dazu ein gibt, ja.
Was gibt's hier?
Zitas Apple 2020.
Aber gibt's bestimmt, gibt's bestimmt nach der Keynote heute.
Reaction Content auf YouTube, ey.
Es wird mir für immer ein Rätsel sein, warum Reaction Content so beliebt ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so, wie Boomer, die nicht verstehen, was an Let's Plays gut ist.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich zu alt dafür, um zu verstehen, was an Reaction Content gut ist.
Du reagierst auch schnell, ja natürlich, da reagiere aber auch ich, warum sich das Leute
angucken, kann ich auch nicht verstehen, wenn ich auf was reagiere.
Aber wenn ich reagiere, reagiere ja wenigstens ich, ich werde nicht verstehen, warum man
sich Reaction Videos anguckt.
Bei manchen Sachen gebe ich zu, bei manchen Sachen, wenn das irgendwas Kontroverses ist
oder irgendwas was besonders Drama ist gerade, ja okay, dann gucke ich mir auch mal irgendwas
an, wo einer drauf reactet, von dem ich vielleicht denke, okay, interessiert mich, was er dazu
zu sagen hat.
Aber bei diesem 0815 Zeug, keine Ahnung, Unge reagiert auf Haftbefehl, nicht Haftbefehl,
auf Tanzverbot, der sich eine Pizza bestellt oder sowas, wo ich denke, who cares, also
erstens ist es mir schon vollkommen wurscht, dass ich Tanzverbot eine Pizza bestellt, selbst
wenn es die Konkräfte Pizza ist und drittens, dass da Unge drauf reagiert, könnte mir nichts
egaler sein.
Aber irgendwie ist das voll angesagt, aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu alt für das
zu kapieren.
Wie gesagt, es gibt auch viele Boomer, die nicht checken oder eigentlich bin ich ja selbst
in der Richtung Boomer, wenn man es so will, die nicht verstehen, was an Let's Plays gut
ist.
Ich bin natürlich Let's Plays, anstatt das Ganze selbst zu spielen.
Da geht es ja gerade darum, dass man das nicht selber spielt.
Reagieren wir mal auf Unges Reagierung.
Okay, das heißt, dann würde ich auf einen reagieren, der darauf was reagiert, der was
reagiert.
Das muss man, das muss man mal, Unge, Unge hat doch bestimmt, hat doch bestimmt reagiert
auf Inscope21 und wie heißt der andere, Gabel, irgendwas, Tim, Gabel, kann das sein, reagiert
auf Karl S., der auf sie reagiert.
So, und wenn man darauf jetzt reagieren würde, das wäre dann quasi Quattruple Reaction.
Die reagieren auf einen, der auf sie reagiert, darauf reagiert einer und darauf würde ich
reagieren.
Nee, das hört irgendwann auf.
Das ist Reacception.
Vielleicht, vielleicht könnte, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber vielleicht könnte es auch
gerade deswegen sein, dass sich Leute quasi React, Reaction Channels oder React Sachen
raussuchen, die quasi das denken, was die Leute auch denken und sich quasi darin bestätigt
fühlen, dass der Reaction Channel auf die Art und Weise reactet, wie sie wahrscheinlich
auch reactet hätten.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Falls mir der Idiot Wollgorte gerade.
Willst du Millionen Views, mach eine Reaction auf Kovana Kriegers Tauchvideo.
Big Brain Idee.
Ich glaube, eine Sache, die tatsächlich, zumindest, zumindest bei den Leuten, die
schon eine Weile dabei sind, was einigen tatsächlich gefallen würde, ist, wenn ich auf, auf mal
ein uraltes Video von mir reakte, so ich reakte auf mich, ich reakte auf den Ultraskiller.
Hey, das fanden, das kam im Stream ultra gut an.
Ich hab mal im Stream auf den Ultraskiller reaktet, das fanden die Leute ganz toll.
Wie hast du unten in der Taskleiste so nice Flächen?
Das ist, das ist standardmäßig, ich hab gar nichts gemacht.
Also, das sieht doch immer so aus oder sieht das nicht immer so aus?
Leute, sieht meine Taskseite, Taskleiste anders aus als bei euch?
Ach so, ich glaube, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Doch, doch, eine Sache hab ich gemacht, ja, ich glaube, das ist das, was du meinst, ähm,
das da musst du machen, Combine Taskbar Buttons, wenn du das hier, wenn du das hier anmachst,
dann hast du sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist die Fault, dass du quasi dann Chrome quasi so als Icon hast, das ist
aber Müll.
Ich will die einzelnen Anwendungen sehen, ich glaube, das ist das Setting, was du suchst,
ja.
Alter, das ist, das ist, das ist total, total lame.
Will das hier auswählen können, weil ansonsten musst du ja erst einmal da draufdrücken und
dann da draufdrücken, das ist total für'n Arsch, äh, einfach, never off.
Ja, äh, Shih Tzu, bei dir ist das kopiert.
Ich mag das null, ich schalte das überall aus, wo ich es ausschalten kann, an irgendwelche
Songs gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Kommt eigentlich mal was um die Channel Points auszugeben, naja, ich hab's euch ja das letzte
Mal vorgelesen, was ich, Moment, Moment, wir gucken, wir gucken nochmal, was es für Möglichkeiten
für Channel Points gibt.
Ich lese euch mal nochmal vor, was es für Channel Points Sachen gibt, falls ich's,
falls ich's finde, äh, Partner, Punkte, Punkte, äh, Kanal, Punkte, hm, Drops, ich kann Drops
einschalten.
Äh, übrigens mein Sound ist gerade weg, ich hör, ich hör keinen Sound mehr, Leute.
Hallo?
Hört ihr mich noch?
Ah, ihr hört mich noch, okay, äh, ich glaub mein Audiointerfell spackt, also ich hör,
ich hör nix mehr hier, warte mal, ich mach mal kurz das Kabel raus, ah, jetzt geht's
wieder, okay, was auch immer das gewesen ist, ähm, ich, ich bin grad, ich finde die Einstellung
nicht, was es für Kanal Punkte gibt, wir hatten das, das letzte Mal hatte ich's doch
schon gefunden, Kanal und Videos, Creator Dashboard, wo kann man auswählen, was man
für, was, wo kann man auswählen, was man für die Kanal Punkte macht, Partner, bestimmt
unter Partner, Partner, Auszahlmethoden, äh, Emotes, Treueabzeichen, Inhalt, Community,
Kanal Punkte, ah, da ist es, okay, Belohnung verwalten, also was haben wir, was haben wir
zur Auswahl, also Nachrichten davor, blablabla, haben wir, ähm, individuelle Belohnung erstellen,
kann man, oh man kann sich sogar selbst was ausdenken, was man machen will, hat da jemand
Big Brain Idee für, selber timeouten, wo, wo ist denn da der Sinn, aber das, das kann
ich, das kann ich euch echt, wenn ihr euch selber timeouten wollt, rufe die Sammlung
auf, okay, ich sperre dich vorübergehend, Belohnung hinzufügen, excellent für 2500
Punkte, äh, Belohnung hinzufügen, okay, so Leute, ihr könnt euch jetzt selbst timeouten,
äh, Wahnsinn, Big Brain, das, das haben wir gebraucht, but why, Leute, warum timeouten
ihr euch, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, excellent, Big Brain Chat, Alter, warum
timeouten ihr euch, Chat, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das geht, Selbstmord im Chat, Alter,
das hört ja, ist ja hier, Chat hört auf, Chat, lass, lass bleiben, der Chat beginnt
Selbstmord, äh, so, okay, ich guck mal, was es noch für Belohnungen gibt, ich guck mal,
was es noch für Belohnungen gibt, ähm, ich aktiviere zwei Minuten lang nur den Emote
Modus, nee, das ist langweilig, eine Umfrage vorschlagen, schlage eine Umfrage vor, die
im Stream ausgeführt werden soll, okay, das ist nicht schlecht, für 7500 lasse ich da
Anzeigen laufen, ich lasse nie Anzeigen laufen, füge einen Befehl deiner Wahl hinzuordnen,
das ist keine gute Idee, für 10.000 Punkte kann man jemand anderen timeouten, nee, für
10 Minuten sogar sperren lassen, oh nee, das ist, das ist fies, das mit den Umfragen
ist nicht schlecht, das mach ich noch mal rein, aber das können wir heute nicht machen,
weil ich muss in 10 Minuten off, so, was könnte man denn für Custom, was könnte man denn
für Custom, ähm, IRL, belohne deine Zuschauer, indem du sie Anweisungen geben lässt, die
du vor der Kamera befolgst, lass mich datten, oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, also
als erstes welche Kamera, Liegestützten Sit-ups, nein, garantiert nicht, für 2500, da komme
ich an Stream nichts anderes mehr raus, als Sit-ups zu machen, Spielbezogen, du darfst
ein Charakter oder Gegenstand, eine Stadt im Spiel benennen, nee, individuelle Belohnung,
ok was kann man da, iPhone Name der Belohnung, Beschreibung, Zuschauer muss Texte angeben,
Kosten, Belohnungsbild, einlösen pro Stream begrenzt, einlösen pro Stream, speiern, ok,
das Memeport steuern, das ist in der Tat eine richtig gute Idee, allerdings müsste ich das
erst einbauen, das ist eine gute Idee, Memeport, Emote deiner Wahl, ein Emote deiner Wahl einblenden
oder irgendwie sowas, einmal, ja das Memeport erweitern habe ich gerade kein Bock drauf,
das würde ich dann von der Hand machen, ich habe nämlich keinen Bock an meinen eigenen
Treckscode mehr ranzugehen, das würde ich dann von der Hand machen, wenn das einer einlöst,
ja, Snapchat, Onlyfans, nicht Snapchat, Snapchat ist out, Onlyfans, was mache ich, Snapchat
User Statistics, Snapchat ist nicht mehr so angesagt, oder, Snapchat ist nicht mehr so
heiße Scheiß, Snapchat ist nicht mehr so krass, also ich meine, in diesem Umfeld ist ja wenn
man nicht doppelt so viel Wachstum hat wie letztes Jahr ist es schon schlecht, oh, was
ist denn das hier, das sehe ich ja gerade zum ersten Mal, ist das Archiv am Start, guck
mal da, Leute, ist das Archiv, es gibt sogar Archivsuche hier, Clips, Spiele, Teams, oh
man kann jetzt sogar die Oberfläche ändern oder was, hohohoho, excellent, ok Streams,
Suchbegriff, KegW, ah das durchsucht nur die Clips oder, oder durchsucht das auch die Streams,
nee nur Clips, Streams, ok BF3, nee die Streams durchsucht es noch nicht, kann das sein,
Aufwachen, da gibt es auf jeden Fall Streams, nee Streams durchsucht es noch nicht, excellent,
das Archiv wird ja immer besser Leute hier, am meisten gespielt haben wir Just Chatting,
gefolgt von Science & Technology, danach Talkshows und Podcasts, danach Creative und dann Overwatch
und BDO, Battlefield, ok, verständlich, hey Max ist Chromium up to date, ist up to date,
hat sogar ein Updater dabei, ja, so Leute es gibt jetzt gleich Mittagessen, ich werde
mich jetzt vom Acker machen, heute Abend 19 Uhr gucken wir uns zusammen, also in 6 Stunden
gucken wir uns zusammen das Apple Event an und mal gucken was dabei rumkommt, ihr seht
uns bis dann, machts gut, CU, was gibt es zu essen, Mozzarella Sticks mit Pommes frites,
bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss,